uh in the depths of this you know quasi
recession we have some of the biggest
boom in AI happening that we've ever
seen and every 14 days it feels like
we're doubling our ability to generate
things with AI and we're continually
impressed by what that means for
companies and startups and so in my mind
like the pace of innovation is just
accelerating and uh if you were excited
about investing in Tech in 2021 you
should be doubly as excited about
investing in Tech today
all right guys bang bang I've got Yuri
here with me I thought a great place to
start this conversation would be on your
background getting into investing uh you
actually are an engineer by training
um and so a lot of Engineers I don't
think have kind of an aspiration to
eventually become a full-time investor
but talk a little bit as to maybe the
pros and cons of being an engineer
turned investor
sure oh first of all thanks for having
me I'm excited to share
um you know for me the the story stars
like I always wanted to be an engineer I
wanted to be an engineer since I was
probably like six years old not like a
real engineer I wanted to be as like to
build software since I was six years old
got my first computer and so when I was
in undergrad I'd actually started a
company with like a web hosting company
that was my first foray entrepreneurship
and when I graduated from undergrad I
was trying to figure out what I wanted
to do next and uh I knew I didn't want
to go work at a big company I had done
an internship long internship at a very
big company and just like wasn't for me
and so it felt like a good thing to do
would be to go and do grad school and so
I started grad school with I think the
intention of never really finishing it
but just having some time to think about
what I wanted to do next and so in grad
school I met another PhD student and he
and I started a company together and
when it was just an idea we decided to
apply with it to Y combinator and that
was back in 2010 and got accepted moved
down to the Bay Area so we're on none of
that like at any point in time that I
think that like oh I'm gonna go and
become an investor you know to me being
an investor meant like public markets
investing I didn't really think of
startup investing as a real thing yeah
like it just then occurred to me that it
wasn't even a possibility and so when we
moved down here and we started building
the business we obviously raised money
we raised the seed round and around the
B round
and along that way I also
um got asked to come and help at Y
combinator and that was my first real
introduction to being a investor on the
Venture side of things so like I started
working at YC in 2014 I worked there for
about five years I was a part-time
partner for four years because I was
still running my company full-time and
then after that uh here on my after my
company got acquired I actually joined
to YC full-time and worked there for
another year and that was you know that
like there it was just like a fire hose
of startups and you start realizing that
oh you can actually like write an angel
check for the startup and that was for
me like the first case you know like I
never really thought of myself as even
an investor when I was at YC but it was
like the first Angel check that I wrote
to a company uh was my introduction to
being an investor and so then when I
left YC
um I actually spent another year trying
to figure out what I wanted to do next I
did I don't think I would start a fund I
thought I would start maybe another
company or maybe join a VC fund I spent
probably half a year talking to a bunch
of VCS and ended up thinking that like
you know I like investing I like seed I
didn't really like the politics of a lot
of funds and ended up deciding that okay
I'll do I'll do my own fund instead
when you think back to your time at YC
it's interesting you went through the
program and then you saw a bunch of
companies go through and I just think of
like practice right you probably didn't
think of it as practice but you were
practicing uh you're developing that
pattern recognition talk a little bit
maybe about some of the things looking
back that you noticed in Founders that
now you have the data points to know who
was successful and who maybe wasn't as
successful as you thought at the time
like are there certain things that you
can point to and say you know now this
is a pattern that I recognize just
seeing so many startups go through the
program over five years
yeah so I think that like it's it's
definitely about reps you know I think
that like as an investor especially at
seed it's all about reps and getting as
many practice reps as you can and the
benefit of YC is I think while I was
there we had funded about a thousand
startups and so you do get to see it at
scale I think that the characteristics
about Founders that really stand out
it's just kind of this like bias towards
action you know that a lot of Founders
should or a lot of people in general
just you know they'll start a project
then they'll just never finish it and
honestly just like finishing a project
is uh one of the you know something that
will set you apart from a huge number of
people and on the YC application one of
the questions that people that gets
asked of each founder is like what's
something impressive other than the
startup that you've actually built right
and to me that question has always been
around like have you actually started
and finished something that you're proud
of
um and so I think that that one is like
that characteristic is really important
and the way that it shows itself is in
velocity right like how quickly are you
moving how quickly are you building
stuff how quickly are you iterating and
learning and making mistakes it's in
scrappiness right it's uh like what are
you able to do without any funding right
like when I went through YC we got like
17 000 and it felt like a lot of money
right now the program obviously gives
you stuff essentially more than that but
the best Founders will be able to
succeed even if they didn't get that
money right and they're able to do that
because they're usually technical right
like the benefit of being a strong
technical founder that can actually
build things is that you don't need a
lot of money you just need a computer
and you can and a Wi-Fi connection and
so those characteristics to me just like
the scrappiness the velocity and just
like getting things done at a very fast
pace are probably the strongest
indicators of success and Founders this
brings up a really interesting point
which is I think a lot of investors
especially when I'm uh talking to these
managers and thinking about investing in
their funds I'll say you know hey what
is your kind of competitive Advantage
how are you going to be able to win
access to these deals and most of them
will revert back to like how helpful
they'll be right and they'll kind of
brag about all the things they're going
to do to help their portfolio companies
which like I do think it's
um uh people with good intentions and
they want to be able to do that but in
some ways you're highlighting the fact
that like maybe the best companies are
the ones who actually don't need any
investor help like they're going to be
successful without funding they're going
to be successful without a bunch of help
externally and so is it something where
you want to find the founders who would
be successful otherwise but then you
want to be helpful in order to help kind
of increase the probability of success
uh I think so I think that those
characteristics are true in the sense
that like you definitely are looking for
Founders where you feel like they will
succeed whether you're there for them or
not but the as an investor I think it's
always a good feeling where you feel it
like you know they will succeed but
maybe you can help them avoid some
mistakes and when I invest in a company
you know uh it is a cliche every
investor says that they try to help I
try to help in a very specific way I was
an engineer that became a Founder that
had to learn how to sell and in the
early days of being a Founder you
usually have to do all the founder sales
yourself so over the sales yourself in
general and so when I invest in
companies part of what I offer is to do
office hours and help when they're going
from like zero to a million in ARR when
they're doing the founder selling when
they're coming up with their first
Pilots success criteria for those Pilots
sales agreements and all those Founders
would figure it out anyway but you know
if they could figure it out in 18 months
and make a bunch of mistakes and maybe I
can help them figure it out in 12 months
instead and make a few fewer mistakes
that actually allows them to hit that
exponential a little bit sooner you know
so I would never take the credit for a
sound or success I think that they do
that all on their own but if I can help
them just move a little bit in the right
direction or avoid a little bit of like
a mistake that they would have otherwise
made I think that for me as an investor
is a very good feeling talk about the
environment at YC while you were there
so one of the aspects that's Most
Fascinating to me is if you take a bunch
of ambitious uh people who are you know
aspiring to this great level of success
frankly in some cases trying to do
Insane Things based on almost any other
measurement from somebody outside of the
building and you put them all in that
same place
is there something special about that
like it how much of the success of these
companies is literally just being around
like other insane highly driven people
and then that forces you uh to kind of
want to level up your game and and
really kind of be successful to compete
I think it's a huge portion of the
success I I think it is the
disproportionate portion of the success
it's like putting a bunch of smart
people together in the same room and I
think that it manifests itself best
because like you could say that oh you
know in the beginning although I see it
like it was a lot about the advice and
the advice is still very very important
but YC is actually open sourced a ton of
that advice you can go to why
commentator.com you can go to Startup
school you can go to the YouTube videos
it's all out there you can consume as
much of it as you want and so in
principle at least you should be able to
go and use all of that advice and build
a company and but you still see these
like disproportionately successful
companies coming out of YC and the
reason in my mind is that you do put
smart people together and you do these
office hours together and every single
week you show up and you say what did
you get done this week and nobody wants
to show up and say that they didn't do
something right and so it creates this
like High Velocity high pressure
environment that's like everyone loves
gloves and it lets you perform at a
level that you otherwise probably
wouldn't have performed on your own the
other thing that it does is it allows
you to use YC as a shield and an excuse
from the external world to say that like
hey for the next three to four months I
am busy doing this thing please don't
disturb me unless it's an emergency
right and so it allows you to really
focus in a way where like if you're just
working on your own and you're working
from home and external type like people
are coming in or grabbing your attention
it's very difficult to actually turn
them down because why Siege Panic gives
you this Shield this community Shield
that says hey for the next three to four
months turn all the distractions off and
go and do this thing and I think it's
those things together it's like the
smart people in one room plus the
ability to actually turn down the noise
for a period of time it's interesting
that you bring up the fact that YC is
open source so much of the advice right
I think that's a net positive uh for the
startup world because obviously now all
these people get access to that advice
and it can help them move the needle on
their companies one of the downsides
though that I'm I've noticed is like
there used to be this pattern
recognition of certain ways that people
thought or certain things that they
would say as you were kind of talking
them to invest in their business and
I've noticed over the years that I
caught like a blog post founder it's
like they went and they read all the
blog posts and now they're just
repeating back the things
yeah
GPD of like startup answers rather yes
and so in some weird way you almost have
to like kind of have a a measurement on
like do they actually believe what
they're saying or they just
regurgitating back what they read in a
blog post and right you know it doesn't
take long to kind of get at the
authenticity of it but I do think that
there is uh not 100 upside it has made
some investors job a little bit more
difficult because now some people have
the right answers but actually they may
not even know what that means in terms
of implementing them
well I think that I think that there's
truth to it I think that like people
have been trained to talk to investors
in a certain way now and partially it's
because of all the videos that people
have watched online but I think the
reality is to your point that you can go
and parse that out pretty quickly one of
my favorite part you know like I think
that you can give all the answers in the
world but like the moment you dig in on
a customer question or something else it
all you know the truth comes out and so
for me one of my favorite questions to
ask Founders is often just like what's
something surprising that you learn from
a user right and I think that question
is really interesting because it probes
like did you actually talk to any users
it also proves like that those users
actually try your product and the
reality is that like same as with a
business plan like the moment that a
user tries your product they're going to
use it in some unexpected way they're
going to do something that you didn't
build it for and um your ability to
internalize that and see how people are
interacting with it will come through in
your answer right and so you can write
read all the blog posts in the World
about how to talk to an investor but
unless you go and spend time with your
customers you're not going to be able to
answer that question very well
when you see YC companies like let's
take stripe
they obviously benefited from the fact
that they were in a program with a bunch
of other potential customers and so
there was like the cross-selling to
other YC companies how much of that do
you think YC has been able to figure out
and we'll use YC as an example but I
think there's a ton of accelerators a
ton of these programs now where people
who are building developer tools or
building you know some sort of
infrastructure for other companies being
put into these programs is not just the
advice it's not just the high Tempo it's
also you're basically getting put side
by side with a bunch of potential
customers and if your product's good and
you're good at sales you should come out
of there with a lot of Revenue as well I
think it's much more true for companies
now than it was when stripe was going
through YC strike one through YC in 2009
and at the time like immediately after
the stride batch was my batch and my
batch was 30 companies so it's not like
you were able to really like build to a
ton of customers right now if you're
going through YC you have the historical
like 4 000 Sorry 4 000 startups that
have gone through the program plus
they're like two to three hundred
startups that are going through the
program right now plus the 200 to 300
they're going to go the next six months
so there's a lot more of that base and
in fact when I was there towards 2017
2018 we have created an event that was
almost like a demo day but instead of
investors we would invite technology
buyers and the cool thing about that
environment was that YC at this point
has such has such a massive alumni
Community there's something like yeah I
think it's probably 10 000 alumni and
many of them are not even working on
their startups they're working at other
companies as technology Executives and
so they would come to the room to check
out the things that new startups are
building and so that became a really
really powerful tool for startups to go
and get early customers I think that
that's helpful and it's certainly
helpful for bootstrapping from zero to
one but at the end of the day you still
have to get comfortable doing sales you
still have to get comfortable doing a
breach on LinkedIn or if you're doing
product growth doing something on Hacker
News or on Twitter or another
environment and so it's definitely
helpful in getting some early users but
it's not I don't think it's like a truly
sustainable way to build your business
whether it's NYC or any other
accelerator really talk about the team
at YC uh while you were there so there's
obviously Paul and Jessica but there's a
bunch of other partners some of them
full-time some of them part-time we're
doing this podcast because I tweeted out
and said you know who are the best young
investors and uh PG so uh kindly tag you
you and said uh no pressure but here we
go
um yeah how much is it the people really
driving the organization versus could
you swap out people now and it's kind of
systematized and it would still be as
great as it is I I don't think it's uh I
don't think that people are Plug and
Play I think the people are really
important I think that you know when I
was away when I started at ycs apartment
in 2014 there were like 10 people there
and obviously the organization now is
much much bigger
um but the heart of that organization is
actually remarkably similar you know
like um uh Gary is back and running YC
now and he was there in 2014 when I
started Mike Seibel who's uh been at YC
I think for as long as I was there it's
still there hard just fyc and so like a
lot of these people who are core at YC
are are still at YC and still providing
feedback to startups the great thing
about it now is that they've actually
built out a lot of other groups around
us so it used to be just partners and
part-time Partners really and a few
people on legal and financed but now
there's an entire software team that
builds tools not just for YC but
actually for the founders like tools
like work at a startup tools like
Bookface that are internal uh Forum plus
uh deals Page Plus you know a ton of
knowledge-based materials and so on that
they've built out and so I think that
the organization now and the people
there now are it's even stronger than it
was back then yeah
um and then talk about Paul and Jessica
specifically in terms of what you've
learned from them or kind of what makes
them so different in terms of being able
to build something like this
I think that they are probably the most
optimistic people I have ever met
um you talk to Paul and Jessica and you
talk to them and they kind of you know
Jessica's like a social radar she's all
about the people and Paul is very
greatly about like the startup and
they're both just like incredible
optimists both about the people in the
startup like he'll talk to Paul about an
idea that you think of this like tiny
idea and he will walk you through how
this idea will take over the world and
at the end of that conversation you're
gonna believe it as much as he believes
it he's not just like blowing smoke he
really does see the vision of how this
company that feels to every other person
in the world that might feel like a toy
could actually become this massive
success and to that is something that I
try to internalize to as much as I can
you know I I have sometimes like a bit
of more of a pessimistic nature to
myself like that I can see a million
ways that something will break but in
Venture in fact killer that actually
doesn't matter right it's all about how
the thing could work like the power law
of it means that it could break 99 times
out of 100 but the one time that it
works it could be Airbnb right and so
being able to see that I think is a huge
superpower and I think he probably has
that better than any other investor in
the world and that's why he's been so
successful Jessica sees that in people
like he just can't her you know
she you to your point like if somebody
comes in and like says the answer uh
that they read on a blog post or they've
you know composed thinking this is how
somebody wants to hear it she will just
be able to reach right through it and uh
that that is for superpower and I think
between the two of them they were able
to just like choose Founders who are
super ambitious and are genuine in that
ambition tackling problems that could be
absolutely massive problems to solve
there's a bunch of companies that people
now know that you invested in flexport
boom Etc talk a little bit as to uh your
own evaluation process then now you have
a fund right now you're kind of doing
this as a full-time job but when you
already know checks for yourself and it
was kind of more Angel Investing did you
just look at a batch and like who are
the craziest people here with the
biggest idea like let me go give them
money or was there some other process no
it's you know it's funny that you bring
those two companies up in particular
because I've been fortunate enough to
invest and I think almost uh almost a
dozen unicorns at this point but those
were some of the earliest ones that I
did and they're both very very memorable
for me
um flexport I have met Ryan I think he
was literally the first person I had
ever done office hours it was uh my fir
you know it was Winter 2014 he was
coming into the YC badge I was just
starting NYC and I remember doing office
hours with them and at the end of the
call you're just blown away you know
here's a guy that has built an
incredibly successful business before
this somebody called the import genius
that was doing tens of millions of
dollars in revenue and he has a chip on
his shoulder that it's not bigger and he
thinks that he can actually build
something even more impressive from what
he learned while doing in Port genius
and I just remember like after that call
I actually texted another YC partner
being like is this you know like am I
reading this wrong and uh he's just like
continued to embrace to this day he
continues to impress you know I think
he's just a Relentless founder
um Blake at Boone had the same thing but
with that you know he's one of the few
Founders that have invested in that
didn't have domain expertise and I
actually got introduced to him before YC
by Sam Altman and Sam said hey you need
to talk to this guy he's building a
supersonic Jet and I remember getting on
the first call with him and and being
like well you know like how are you
going to do that and um he says to me
well I'm a pilot and I'm hugely
passionate about airplanes and like I've
already been talking to all these people
and I thought he was crazy I thought it
was just like the craziest thing I'd
heard uh I was a pilot I am a pilot and
like I couldn't and I have an
engineering background and I've taken
some aerospace engineering courses and I
still couldn't build a super sonic yet
and so initially I actually passed and
then you came to YC and I followed along
with him through YC and the things that
impressed me about him is he has this
tenacity about him where he was able to
convince experts to join him on this
crazy Journey you know and like he was
able to convince Engineers from SpaceX
to quit and he was able to convince
Engineers from Lockheed to quit and he
was able to convince Richard Branson to
donate resources from Virgin America
which was an aerospace company to
actually help him and so in my mind it
went from a question of okay well you
probably don't have the expertise
personally to build this job but you
have this ability to recruit people
around you who believe in this Vision as
much as you do that there is a non-zero
probability that you actually could
build this Jet and if that's true then
that opportunity is massive right and so
I had invested a little bit after YC
demo they still kind of a seed round
they could have invested even earlier
but at that point I was convinced that
like he will be able to recruit the
people and you know now he's recruited
somebody that was a chief engineer at
Gulfstream for 30 years right and so
like there's a real team in place that
has a non-zero like a pretty good chance
at actually building a cashier So It
ultimately is like sorry just to finish
the thought it's just like It ultimately
is all about the people in both cases
I'm gonna unpack this a little bit more
like was he able to convince people
because him because the idea was so big
like what do you think was so convincing
to get all of these really impressive
people to leave their companies to come
and work on what you know you at initial
thought was like this is insane there's
no way they can do this
well I think that it was it wasn't like
I mean people have built a supersonic
jet before and so that in itself wasn't
insane but it's um you know he
approached it from first principles and
he said well you know there isn't like
one 10x thing that we need to do we can
do better today than we weren't able to
do with the Concord but there's a lot of
these like 30 improvements we have
better Wing Composites we have better
fuel efficiencies we have better engines
we have better fuel sources or cheaper
fuel sources and together we can put all
of these things together and build a
supersonic jet that's maybe like three
times as affordable or four times as
affordable as a Concord
um and I think that when he went to
people a lot of these people who are
working at Lockheed or at Boeing you
know they're working on Tiny projects
that take decades to build and honestly
like a lot of these companies have lost
some of their ambition like if you look
at what Lockheed used to do if you reach
conchworks you know and you see the
SR-71 or you see the U2 or you see the
stealth providers and then you see like
the stuff that they're doing today it's
not as exciting and I think if you're an
ambition as engineer you want to go and
work on something that even if it
doesn't work you're going to feel like
you've moved the needle and so I think
that you know when you run into someone
who's that ambitious and is so genuine
in that ambition you just want to join
them on the journey and say screw it
let's go and try and see and maybe we
succeed and maybe we fail but at least
we will have tried right
you went into YC in 2010 uh which is
kind of right during that Global
Financial Crisis coming out of it uh you
then were in and around YC in early
stage investing
um all through kind of the decade-long
bull market you then lived through the
craziness of kovid and the like one
month recession that we had then then
again here we go up again in another
kind of crazy bull market with all the
quantitative easing and then obviously
2022 we get this big crash in public
markets and asset prices and so whether
you count that as like one cycle two
cycles however you want to think about
it you've seen ups and downs now in
early stage uh markets how do you
evaluate where we are now are you
looking at this as we're still in some
sort of compression type phase maybe
seed was more insulated from compression
versus like other parts of the market
just talk to me about like the market
conditions in early stage investing
yeah I think that I mean
the correct that the bull market that
happened in 2020 is certainly an anomaly
right and I think that it led to a lot
and maybe it was kind of the tail end of
a long bull market where interest rates
weren't zero but they're low and so the
behavior was starting to get ingrained
in people the valuations were already
creeping up and then everything that
happened in 2020 just like completely
blew it up and so that in my mind that
correction always had to happen the the
one thing that I feel fortunate about is
I never really got caught up in the hype
of everything is going to be a 15
billion dollar company and so entry
valuation still matter and so I I tried
to continue to be a little bit diligent
about how I'm approaching investments
from first principles and like through
the valuations matter how big are these
opportunities what does it mean like to
be a 10 billion dollar company you have
probably have to be at about a billion
dollars in Revenue what does that mean
right like what does that look like I
think that today where starting to come
back to that first principle thinking
where people are saying okay you know
you want to build a billion dollar
business that means you need to do a
hundred million dollars in Revenue how
much of the market you have to capture
to do 100 million dollars in revenue and
what does that mean for your entry
valuation today and so I think that
correction had to happen I think that it
happened fastest at the latest stages
that the public markets right investors
immediately retweeted the moment the
interest rates started rising and they
could park their money somewhere else
and it slowly trickles down backwards
and so you saw you know I think that the
late stage markets private markets are
frozen the series B and C markets which
are kind of mid-stage are pretty Frozen
and the series a markets are happening
but in fits and starts at seed I think
that you know it took a longer time to
correct people took a longer time to
absorb it and part of me feels like the
real correction they have still not
happened because I think that there's a
lot of these large unicorn companies
that are unfortunately going to end up
either getting washed out or recapped
and a lot of early stage investors
haven't and certainly you know they
might have these funds that have been
marked off to 5x and 6X and they just
haven't actually marked them down to see
what what that performance looks like
and that then realize like what does
that mean for their Investments going
forward but you do see you know like I
think in 2022 at the top of it you would
see seed Investments happening at like
50 to 100 million valuation so it's just
wild with zero revenue and in some cases
just a day I think that that pretty
quickly reset back to 20 and then you
see it resetting back to 15 and I'm now
once again seeing things happening kind
of in the 8 to 12 range which is I think
a much as a valuation post money
valuation range is a much healthier
evaluation rate for companies
um and so I think that where we are now
from a valuation perspective is much
better
from a general seed investment
perspective I personally am as bullish
on the market now on the seed Market now
as I was in 2022 and 2021 I think that
technology is one of those secular
Trends it just doesn't care about what
you know the interest rate environment
looks like in the depths of this you
know quasi recession we have some of the
biggest boom in AI happening that we've
ever seen and every 14 days it feels
like we're doubling our ability to
generate things with AI and we're
continually impressed by what that means
for companies and startups and so in my
mind like the pace of innovation is just
accelerating and uh if you were excited
about investing in Tech in 2021 you
should be doubly as excited about
investing in Tech today when you say
that the valuations are healthier and
kind of that 8 to 12 range talk a little
bit about maybe from the founders
perspective right many Founders are here
it sounds amazing to raise money at a 50
million dollar post money on the deck
but maybe talk a little bit about the
Perils of doing so and you know for
those that haven't seen kind of the
downsides why is having that healthy
early stage valuation so important to
the success of a company
I think there's a couple of reasons why
do so there's a couple of reasons why a
early stage valuation actually matters
the first reason is that
um if you raise it a very high valuation
you now have very high expectations so
for the founders that raised that 50
million evaluations for the seed rounds
right the expectation for their next
round their investors want to see a
double or a triple on the evaluation so
they're expecting them to go raise at
100 to 150 that might be off the table
but even to raise at 50 now might be off
the table because to raise it 50 the
there the new investors are going to
want to see maybe like two and a half
three maybe five million dollars in
Revenue right and
it's very likely that if you raised you
know 18 to 24 months ago you're not at
three to five million dollars in Revenue
today and if you're not a three to five
million in Revenue today you now need to
do a bridge or you might need to do
something that looks like a Down Round
And so now you're killing morale for
your investors you're killing morale for
your team and you're killing morale for
yourself right you could have done the
exact same round at a 20 million
evaluation and probably hit the exact
same mile so there's this weird thing
that happens when you raise money is it
tends to get spent and it's kind of
irrelevant whether you've raised a
million two million five million or 10
million you usually end up spending it
in around 18 to 24 months and I think
that when you're raising money you know
you raise like 10 million on 50 and all
you have to show for it is three to four
million dollars in revenue is just makes
your life significantly harder you could
have done the exact same thing where you
would have raised 2 million on 12 or 2
million on 15. probably been scrappier
probably probably hits very similar
Milestone still and maybe even have been
a little bit more focused because you
had less money right and now your next
round maybe it won't be at 150 but you
have room to go to 30 or 40.
um whereas if you had raised at 50 going
to 30 or 40 feels like a like a loss not
like a win right and so you kind of end
up with these two situations where it's
hard to get an up round it's hard to get
a flat round it's hard to get a Down
Round nobody wants to come in as an
investor as a later stage investor you
don't really want to come in and uh
price it lower nobody will be mad at you
if you pass on investing but people will
be mad at you if you actually lower the
valuation and for investors who all
co-invest together over a long period of
time that actually becomes something
that they think about right it's just
like the relationship down the road not
just with that company but with the
other investors on the cap table and so
I think that those high valuations do
cause problems in those cases some of
the companies will grow in to it right
like there's a number of companies that
raised 100 million dollars of like two
billion valuation in 2022 and they have
five years of Runway and they will grow
into those valuations I think that's
totally fine but the risky ones are the
ones that raise like five million at 40
or 50 and spent it all and now need
their next round of fun
talk about those long-term relationships
obviously uh organizations like y Su
have been around for a long time there's
a partnership there's something that is
pulling people kind of together there's
a brand uh when you go out on your own
now all of a sudden it's more like
personal relationships right there's no
uh kind of early stage Mafia for example
it's kind of a bunch of people who are
unilaterally working to invest and find
deals but you most likely are not going
to take down an entire round right
you're not going to go and kind of do it
yourself you need other investors both
uh as peers in the early stage but also
you need other investors who are going
to come in for the series a or series B
and kind of continue to fund the company
and so how do you think about those
relationships and maybe some things that
you do to help cultivate the
relationships but also some things that
you look for uh where you say Hey you
know this person may be a nice person
but I might not want to actually invest
with them in the future
well I think that like those
relationships matter whether you're a
solar GP or you're a part of a larger
organization so like you know a lot of
series a funds don't do series B's and
so they all have relationships with
funds that do do serious fees and those
funds know that if they come in and you
know blow up a cap table of a series a
investors company that series a investor
may not send another company that way
because they're not going to want to do
that and so I think that those
relationships uh you know they spend
many many years and
um they they it is at the end of the day
a human business you work with people
that you like to work with and so if you
do a deal and then you invite another
investor you don't just think of it as
like oh I invited this big fund it's
actually I invited this person at this
big fund and here's how they behave when
I invited them
um I think that as a solo GP at seed
there are more of these types of
relationships that you manage so because
like you said you know I usually don't
dig down and tie around myself I will
bring other co-investors to the table
that uh and like there's a long list of
investors that I'd love to work with
sometimes it's bigger funds sometimes
it's a bunch of other Angels sometimes
it's other seat funds that depends more
on like what the company needs right
like I'll meet a company I'll see like
oh you could really use uh people with
the following expertise here's some
angles that really have that expertise
and have the time to spend with you on
this or you know oh you really want to
have a big seed fund to take down the
rest of the round because you want
someone who's really committed here are
some good seed funds that are going to
spend time with you that you should talk
to so that roster is pretty deep
um but you do remember like if somebody
and if somebody misbehaves as an
investor and misbehaving is not really
about like valuation that they said
misbehaving it's like you broke a term
sheet or you you know you mistreated a
company or you leaked information to a
competitor or you did something else
that stuff gets remembered right and you
will think twice if uh if you're going
to bring that investor again into a deal
or even if you see that investor
involved in a deal
when you look at the companies who have
done the best in your portfolio versus
the companies who did not succeed are
there things that are either habitual or
certain types of decisions early on
where you can start to see probabilities
changing we talked about individuals
being Scrappy having a bias for action
and kind of the Velocity at which they
made decisions but what about the
companies themselves are there certain
things that you can see and attribute to
oh this increases probability of success
or this decreases that probability
I think that
the it's an interesting question and I
think that it's hard to generalize in
terms of like is there something that
really repeats itself
um in my mind the biggest risk to a
company is not launching soon enough you
know and that I think that's more of an
individual thing than a company thing
but like oftentimes you will convince
yourself that the product has to be
perfect before launching and you'll go
and spend two years three years building
it in a vacuum and maybe with like one
or two beta users but sometimes not even
that and then you come out and you bring
it to Market and it turns out that the
market didn't want it and so the you
know building in public I think helps
alleviate some of that at least you'll
find out very quickly that people
actually want that or not but in I think
most of the businesses where things
haven't worked out at the end of the day
they just weren't building something
that people wanted and with startups
it's about finding that the answer to
that question as quickly as you can like
do people actually want what you're
building and
um the ones that have failed I don't
know if it's universally true but like
many of them just didn't launch soon
enough didn't and get in front of their
customers soon enough and didn't have
the opportunity to Pivot or learn from
that if they as if they would if they
had done it sooner right because they
would have had more Runway to go and
actually spend the time
this idea of finding out whether people
want your product or not kind of
reinforces
um earlier you're saying that PG could
see something that was small and
extrapolate it out and say this is how
it could become very big we know that
many of the most successful Tech
startups in history have started out
either with very small ideas or kind of
look like a toy right as many people
have pointed out and so Airbnb had you
know air mattresses in their kitchen you
look at Facebook and it was literally
kind of like is this person attractive
or not how much of the successful
companies in your portfolio started out
as like this little thing and then over
time they almost kind of got more
ambitious they got Bolder they got more
courage to kind of go for a very big
company versus there was uh Master
planning and somebody said hey you know
what I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
accomplish a then they went and started
on step one and were able to execute and
accomplish that
I think it's very common uh I need to go
look through the portfolio to figure out
like how frequent it really happens but
even like in the case of flexboard right
the early version of flexport was not a
digital Freight forwarder it was much
more like a they were digitizing import
export documents which is something that
Ryan had seen when he was doing import
Geniuses that like it was all happening
on paper and fax machine and he felt
that that alone was a big opportunity
and so he started from that and now I
mean their ambitious have grown
dramatically right and I think you could
have looked at Flex support at the time
and being like well you know this is
like very narrow and not that
interesting
um but it turned out that honestly like
even if they had just done that I think
that would have been a big opportunity
but they just realized that as they went
down that path and they spent more time
with their customers so much more of
this Freight forwarding world is broken
that they were able to continue growing
from there now I'll give you another
example one of the companies this is a
very cool company it's a company called
solugen this is also an investment
before wayfinder this is a company that
makes carbon negative chemicals right
and they started here they had this like
little reactor at the YC demode which
was able to take algae and carbon
dioxide and create hydrogen peroxide so
like just a cleaning chemical and you
could have just said well like you know
that that's not particularly interesting
there's already a lot of ways to build
cleaning chemicals
um they had a number of advantages
already but beyond that they had the
aspiration to do much more than just
hydrogen peroxide right and now they
make I think almost like a dozen
different uh chemicals all in these like
organic carbon negative waves where
they're actually taking CO2 out of the
environment and creating these chemicals
and again like I don't think that they
would have known in the early days that
there was room to like build or which
other chemicals I'd actually be able to
do the only thing they knew for sure is
that they were able to make hydrogen
peroxide and they were actually selling
that hydrogen peroxide already and so I
think that like with a lot of these
companies uh and now by the way like if
you go look them up online they have
this massive bioreactor in Texas uh
super super cool and it's just built
creating dozens and dozens of chemicals
and so I think that for a lot of
businesses it would start as an idea or
like at least as a wedge something
that's narrow but has a real problem
that you're solving and ideally you're
solving this problem 10x better than
it's already being solved and then you
go and you expand from there and you go
where the customers take you you know as
opposed to like try and make it up on
your own the customers will usually show
you the way in terms of where the
opportunity Lies over time talk about
your relationship with Founders and kind
of the tempo in which you communicate or
kind of help a company I'm assuming that
that is much more frequent and kind of
much more Hands-On in the earliest
stages in the seed round or in the
pre-seed round but as a company gets
larger uh you know to flex Port Etc they
obviously have many more investors they
have entire teams now like that
relationship kind of evolves over time
and so maybe talk about the ideal
scenario as to like how you as an early
stage investor can uh interact with and
communicate early on and then how do you
kind of see that in an ideal manner
evolving over that period
yeah that's a great question so I I
think that you know where I am most
valuable to a Founder is again kind of
when they're going from that zero to a
million ARR point and the way that I
helped there is anything from a regular
office hours or even just being
available on iMessage or WhatsApp so
every company I invest in gets my phone
number they can text me they can call me
we can talk about things as they come up
uh some companies I every company also
gets a private link to my calendar so we
can set up office hours as frequently as
they need some companies I actually meet
with on a regular Cadence maybe once a
month or once a quarter but it's
completely up to the founders it's not
something that I dictated I just say
like like you can use me in any number
of these ways you tell me how you want
to do it then the second part of that is
just like well what do we spend time on
and you know I can help you uh I I can
help you with anything that any investor
can help you with but I think where I
can uniquely help you is that when
you're trying to do those first sales
agreements and you're you're a technical
person you've never sold to somebody
before and you're trying to navigate
that environment and you're dealing with
procurement and you're closing your
first couple of deals and then even when
you're maybe hiring your first account
executive or your first sales person
I've got it on calls and interviewed
those people eventually you know you'll
get to a series a you'll get a board
you'll get a VP of sales or a director
of sales you won't need me as much and
that's totally fine I'll still be there
if you want to talk about it and there
are still calendars who I've raised you
know even billion dollar evaluation
rounds and reach out to me to talk about
a particular deal or talk about a
particular case that's happening with
one of their customers or even investors
and I will always pick up the phone and
my goal is to be like one of the fastest
responding investors on your cap table
but uh I usually end up taking more of a
back seat after the after the series a
the reality is that like when you help a
Founder in those early days they tend to
remember that and uh you know you
remember your first million dollars in
sales much more than your remember your
next 5 million or your next 10 million
and so I end up being pretty close with
most of the portfolio Founders uh that
you know that I'm fortunate enough to
work with and it becomes at that point
much more of a friendship than just like
a pure investor and found a relationship
um and so I still talk to them I still
check in but I try to make sure it's one
of a an investor I know has this phrase
where it's like I want to be in your
corner not in your kitchen and I really
think about that you know like I don't
want to feel like I'm like looking over
you and just continually asking how are
things going I just want to help if I
can and if you don't want my help that's
totally cool
talk about uh being a kind of a solo
capitalist right or an individual
investor today you've got to fund but
you have no Partners
um I think that you're open to
eventually finding a partner if uh if
the right person comes across but what
are the pros and cons of operating as an
individual investor rather than have
kind of the investment committee and a
lot of you know staff and infrastructure
and things like that that maybe larger
funds have
right so even as a solo GP you do end up
having a lot of people helping you so
you know I have a funded man I have a
legal team I have accountants there's a
lot of people in the back office making
sure that the fund is actually working
day to day and where the solo part comes
in is on making investment decisions
sourcing companies and helping the
companies down the road but even that
part you know I'm fortunate enough that
my a lot of my LT base are incredibly
successful entrepreneurs and Founders
who are always interested and part of
the reason they're investing with me is
that they want to meet other Founders
and they want to help other Founders
they just don't have the time to Source
the deals themselves the advantages of
being solo is like you said like you
know I don't have an investment
committee if I need a Founder I can make
a decision incredibly quickly there's
um you know it can be after a phone call
or it can be after a couple of phone
calls but I don't need to go and
convince the rest of my Partnerships and
I think that where this is powerful is
most investment decisions are
non-consensus like the most of the best
investment decisions are not consensus
they're non-obvious and if you are
spending time trying to convince a
partnership you will lose some of those
deals the downside is that you don't
really have someone that's truly aligned
with you to try and figure out like
should we do this deal and maybe
challenge you in some of that thinking
and so it's up to you to either come up
with the reasons you know where things
may not work or find people that will
help challenge you and that is also
where you know I lean on other LPS who
are founders on entrepreneurs for
feedback I talk to a number of other GPS
where we share deals or we think through
deals together and ultimately the
benefit there is that like even if one
of us doesn't want to do the deal and
the other person wants to do the deal
we're able to do that and so that that
helps a fair bit but I think even in
today's environment where deal flow has
slowed down the ability to move quickly
and make a decision quickly helps you
win deals and the competitive deals or
the best deals still often at times end
up being competitive and so that that is
a real superpower what I find
fascinating that maybe many people don't
know if they haven't been kind of an
early stage investor and focus on it
full time is how much of the deal flow
comes from other investors versus you
went you know you were scouring the
internet and found some website that no
one's ever heard of before and called up
the founder or the founder listens to
this podcast and it's like oh let me go
email them or track them down like a lot
of the deal flow does come from other
investors and so how do you think about
signals in terms of deals that other
investors are sending to you or talking
to you about and making sure that you
actually get a good signal versus maybe
this is just an investor who needs to
fill it around and so they're kind of
shopping it around to people
yeah I mean if people you'll end up with
a reputation if you do that right like
there is a question of like why am I
fortunate enough to see this deal right
that is a question that you always ask
yourself uh generally speaking I'm
fortunate enough that most of the
investors that send deals my way want
they they are already committing
themselves and they want me in the round
because they think I can help a Founder
with sales or go to market or you know
they think that I'm that I have a deep
understanding of the domain or the space
and so it is true you know 99 of my deal
flow comes in through a referral one way
or another it might be through the YC
Community it might be through an LP it
might be through another investor that I
coined this with I think that in my
entire history as an investor I've
probably only done maybe two deals
through cold Outreach
um and so it's not to say that it's not
possible but it's always a little bit
easier to cut through the noise if it's
coming in through a warm referral and uh
it's just a matter of like why is this
person referring something by way right
like are they personally excited by this
if sometimes it's not a fit so like I
have done deals where a bigger fund is
passing but they think it might be
interesting to me and I know they're not
passing because they're not passionate
about this but they're passing because
it just doesn't struck really work for
them you know the check size that's
available or something else doesn't
structurally work for them and so in
cases like that like I'll still take a
look at it
um yeah I I don't really get like I
think that for me I I'm fortunate enough
that I don't have a lot of those
referrals where I'm worried that
somebody's just like throwing something
my way
um to see if I'll be like greater full
funding it it's basically if you're high
quality and you act in a high quality
way then naturally you're going to
coalesce with other high quality
investors who are acting in a high
quality way right it's kind of like over
time I think there's just it's like
culling of people who don't fit into
that mold and then you eventually just
build a high trust I know another thing
that you've talked about in terms of
high trust and you mentioned to me
earlier is if you ever were to bring on
a partner and go from one investor to
two or three investors uh you actually
want High trust with the person but you
want to disagree on almost everything
and so describe a little bit this
balance of like high disagreeableness
with each other but also the need for
trust
right well so I think that like if
you're bringing on a partner there's
maybe three reasons that you bring on a
partner as a VC uh one reason is that
that partner can bring in additional
capital and you're trying to scale your
firm and they have contacts that you
don't have another reason is that they
have deal flow that you don't have so
maybe they're they come from a different
Community or something else and they're
seeing deal flow and the third reason
would be that they can help you make
better decisions right and that reason
is the one where I'm leaning on the
title like you want someone that you
trust but you don't agree with because
if you bring on somebody that you trust
and you agree with you're going to make
the same decisions that you would have
made anyway so you're not really getting
any benefit from having the second or
third person on and what you really want
is someone that you believe in you think
incredibly highly of but they will make
decisions that you would not have made
because those best deals are the ones
that are contentious and you probably
you know like they're not consensus
contentious and not consensus and so so
that means that you're going to give the
keys to the money that LPS have
entrusted you with to somebody else and
that person is going to write checks
where in your bones you might be afraid
that like this deal is not going to work
because of whatever reason but you trust
this person and you trust that they have
a vision here that
um that you're just missing right and
even like in those cases you probably
want to be aligned on the people so you
want to say that oh you know we're going
to invest in high quality people where
they're high integrity and like all of
these characteristics are met but maybe
we invest in different sectors and like
this person looks at biotech which I
don't understand or they look at fintech
and they have a very specific angle on
fintech and so they might do something
that I otherwise would not have done and
so that that's kind of like the ideal
person that you want right like they are
aligned with you on values but they will
do things or look at uh spaces where
like you don't know or you don't have
personal conviction in and that's very
difficult like you it ideally is going
to be someone that you've done deals
with before again over a long period of
time because Venture is a long you know
it's a long game where you it takes a
long time to figure out whether anybody
is good or not and then it's it's hard
to do that I you know I think that VCS
will talk to potential partners for
years sometimes before bringing somebody
on when you think about uh the partners
that is kind of up here how do you think
about building a firm in terms of uh
junior Partners or Associates or other
types of roles within a firm
I think that it's It's Tricky you know
there are certainly firms that build
um that build people essentially they
like bring up people from inside on the
bring in Associates and they're
elevating them and they'll train them
and I don't know that I would have the
expertise how to do that and so for me
to bring on an associate feels tricky
um I also think that like an associate's
job is very very difficult you know
they're like the s in some cases they're
like the SDR like the sales development
right or the VC fund they have to go and
call a lot of Founders and the founders
don't want to answer the phone with them
they only want to talk to a partner and
um it's you know it's a difficult role
to succeed in so for me and for my fund
I probably wouldn't do Associates I
think I would bring on a partner that
ideally would be equal to me that I can
just offload some of the responsibility
to and then at scale maybe have like a 3
three-person partnership no Associates
no
um outside of maybe some folks do like
help with back office and other analysis
but like on the investment side I think
it would just be an equal partnership
and I think the example there that I
think of is Benchmark right
I just don't think they have any
Associates there and so when you think
about those small teams is there
something around consensus decision
making versus the ability for anyone
partnered to uh invest I know some of
these firms even if they have 10 or less
people right there's hey it's all
consensus uh and other firms they're
like no if you have a consensus decision
by Nature it can't be a contrarian bet
and so therefore each individual partner
can do a certain amount like how do you
think about decision making once you get
past one person
I think you have to allow for
non-consensus decision making there are
some firms that are so good that they do
even unanimous you know it has to be a
unanimous investment
um and they're very successful I think
like some of the top funds in the world
do do it that way but many many funds
don't succeed in that way and in my mind
I think you will again kind of going
back to the point if you want someone
that you trust implicitly and if you
trust them implicitly then you have to
allow them to do a deal that you maybe
would not have done yourself and so I
don't think you can do a consensus-based
deal you can got you can give them all
the reasons that you're like sorry I
don't think you need something you don't
want to do deals where like you all have
to vote and you know you have to have a
majority approval to do a video
especially like in a two to three person
partnership I think that what you want
is you want a place where the partners
feel free to voice their concerns and
say like this is where I'm worried that
things might go wrong or this is where
I'm worried about the space or something
else but if you want to do the deal and
you believe in it then I believe in you
you know and you're my partner and like
go for it that would be my ideal
environment
talk about fundraising
um when you go from a partner at YC and
you've got obviously the work at YC but
you also have your personal portfolio of
Angel Investing but you say hey I'm
going to go out on my own I'm going to
raise a fund
um I'm assuming a big portion of what
LPS are underwriting is your past
Investments but how do those
conversations go in terms of them trying
to underwrite you as a fund manager you
as someone who yes you have accountants
yes you have fund admins but you still
have to manage those people you still
have to make these decisions you still
have to do portfolio construction like
like there are some things here now when
you're using other people's money versus
just personal Angel Investing that they
want to understand and so what was your
experience like when you went out to
raise that first fund
yeah it's funny you know so first of all
my timing with fundraising has been
horrible for both funds I um I started
fundraising fund one in March of 2020 so
right as we hit the one month recession
I started raising fund two in April of
2022 so right as the market turned down
so I'll tell you when I raise fund free
because you should probably just go sell
everything and
and uh so that that certainly did not
help right the other thing that I found
surprising honestly people talk about uh
these being an entrepreneur when you're
a VC and you're starting a fun but I can
tell you that like as a past company
founder 99 of what you do as a Founder
is much harder than your day-to-days
that we see the only thing that I think
is harder as if you see is fundraising
and I did not expect that and the reason
is that like as a Founder you're
generally looking for a market of one or
maybe a market of like three to four
people who give you the money you know
if you're raising a series a that entire
series a is going to come from one
investor if you're raising a seed round
that's probably going to come from a
handful of investors but if you're
raising a fund it might come from 99
investors right that's your limit on how
many investors you can have and you may
very well hit that limit and so you need
to go and convince dozens of people to
come along to the right with you and
most of the time those people don't want
to be more than like 10 to 20 of your
funds and by definition they're more
risk-averse right they are these are not
people like in Venture we're very used
to risk I'm very used to underwriting
that it's either going to be a massive
outcome or a zero but these people are
looking for outcomes that are going to
be like you know a great fund return is
at 5x that's like honestly the top
decile right like top quartile fine
performance I think is a 3X top decile
is 5X but like I said when you're
investing in companies you're looking
for 50 access right and so the people
that are underwriting funds are
underwriting your past performance your
history your everything they really are
like looking at you through a microscope
and I was not prepared for that on San
Juan
um it just it was uh it you know it was
a bit of a surprise and so I do think
that my past track record helped a lot I
think that uh you know that my angel
portfolio is deep enough and was
representative enough of what I wanted
to focus on as an investor that people
were able to look at it and say okay
that makes sense the other thing that I
did is I didn't try to go from like you
know writing 50k to 100K checks to all
of a sudden writing million dollar
checks I was going from 50k checks to
writing 40 million dollar checks or 350k
checks so the leak wasn't as big like
investors could look at it and say okay
you were writing similar enough size
checks we believe that you can continue
doing that without adverse selection
um but even then it was you know I
talked to hundreds of LPS and I got
hundreds of rejections and even now you
know I still get like for fun too I got
a ton of rejections as well
um and so it's uh it's it's a challenge
it's like it's not easy this is the only
part of the job that's genuinely not
easy the other part of the job is you
don't know if you're investing well but
that will take a longer time why do you
think uh rejections like can you bucket
them into uh certain categories is it oh
it's a first time fund I don't back
first time funds is it uh your track
record as a fund manager isn't there I
don't look at you know Angel portfolios
like what would you say went into some
of those buckets and and less about like
you know what are the things that people
uh wanted to pass on you for and more so
for people who want to go raise a fund
what are some of the things that they
should be prepared for that maybe don't
have anything to do with them
specifically it could be structural
things right it could be kind of Market
condition things anything like that
yeah so I think that like in general you
know I take the approach of like hear
the no but not the why so you get a
million rejections and it's very
difficult to figure out what the real
reason is but there are a number of
rejections that I think are common for
first-time managers the solo GP thing is
an issue for some funds that's less of
an issue today than it would have been
like five years ago but you know some
some funds like solo GP some funds will
say we will never back a solo GP even
though the reality is that like
Partnerships blow up all the time right
more likely to blow up a partnership
than you are to blow up if you're solo
um the fact that like you're they a lot
of people won't give you credit for your
angel portfolio they'll say oh you had
like proprietary deal flow or you had
something else that maybe doesn't exist
now
um and so they are going to want to see
it repeat they want to make sure that
you didn't just get lucky and that
portfolio and you're able to do it again
in your next portfolio and your next
portfolio a lot of people just won't do
fund ones because they think that
there's a big learning curve here and
maybe you will never raise a fund two or
fun free because you realize that this
isn't for you and so for a lot of
institutional investors they are looking
at you not from a oh I'm going to invest
in your fund one they're looking at us
I'm going to invest in your fund One
Fund two fund three fun four fund five
we're gonna work with you for 20 years
right and so it's worth it for them to
wait two to three fund Cycles again
because there isn't that much of that
fomo of like oh I'm Gonna Miss This like
50x outcome and see how you're doing and
come back and revisit this so I try not
to take those personally
um so I think that like it's you know
it's uh if you're trying to scale the
check sizes if as an angel you're
writing 10K checks and now you're saying
I'm gonna write half a million dollar
checks people are gonna say well you
know it's very easy to get a 10K check
into a round but once you're writing
half a million dollar check you might
actually be out taking allocation from
somebody else and so prove to me that
you're able to do that right and I I
think that like all of those are valid
reasons and you do in some ways need to
earn the right to write those bigger
checks like if I start did in 2014
trying to write half a million dollar
checks I would have gone in the worst
companies right so it's very so like
those I think are all good reasons and
those I think are the biggest real
reasons that don't have to do with you
personally oh the other one it's funny I
mean people get very thematic you know
in 2020 everyone was asking me if I like
how much of my fund is going to be
crypto in 2023 or 2022 everyone was
asking me how much of my phone's going
to be AI
um and so LPS do sometimes end up
chasing those themes and they'll say oh
I I am allocated on uh fintech and I
really want Nai fund I personally
believe that it's C this is a mistake
you should focus on the people and let
the people lead the way
um like I'm not a huge thematic investor
I think it makes sense at later stage
but probably less so at the early stage
but these are all like very valid
Reasons from an LP perspective is there
one major surprise since you started the
fund that you kind of point to and said
I definitely did not expect this
I think the biggest one was the
fundraising
um the
uh I don't know if there's other like
most of the other things I think because
I was Angel Investing for a while and I
had a pretty long portfolio just on my
angel side I got down about 45 50 Angel
investments before I started a fund I
was already familiar with a lot of the
logistics there I think that some of the
um
is you just get surprised by like how
much fun that men work there is you know
you think of it as oh I'm just gonna go
and invest and uh I'm gonna work with
Founders but a lot of your day ends up
being spent on quarterly reports or on
the financial statements or on the audit
that your fund is undergoing right
um or like on the banking systems
collapsing and you need to find banking
partners and so a lot of those things
are you know that it's not the stuff
that you think about when you think that
I'm gonna go and work with Founders and
write checks to those Founders that's
great
um my last question for you is uh we
talked earlier about reps and how the
important that is to getting better as
an faster and kind of developing that
pattern recognition is there anything
else that you do to improve as an
investor talk to people read podcasts
like what else can you do to become a
better investor you have to be
incredibly curious right the to be an
investor especially an early stage
investor you're trying to invest in the
future and so you have to have this like
deep curiosity about what the future
could be like uh without prejudice right
like let people show you the future meet
them and try and understand it from
their eyes and so I think that you know
you have to be willing to spend a lot of
time with people you have to read a lot
the reading can come in a variety of
ways you can read books you can read
podcasts or sorry you can listen to
podcasts you can read blog posts where
you can honestly curate a Twitter feed
and learn a ton from that Twitter feed
because there's so many people now
sharing their knowledge and their
insights online for free
um but fundamentally you just have to be
curious right and you have to be an
optimist you can't make money as a
venture investor you can make money in
the public markets by being a pessimist
by you know shorting stocks and buying
puts but as an early station investor or
a venture investor in general you have
to be optimistic about the future and so
those things like that Curiosity and
optimism you can't really like you can't
fake it you know it has to come
naturally to you and you you cultivate
it by surrounding yourself with smart
people
I love it Yuri this has been uh
absolutely fantastic I really enjoyed
talking to you and I've learned a bunch
in this conversation where can we send
people to find you on the internet
my Twitter is uh my first name Yuri and
my last initial
s-y-u-r-i-s and then the fun website is
wayfinder.com but honestly I'm a solo GP
so my Twitter is probably a better place
awesome well listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this and we'll
definitely do it again in the future
awesome thank you it was great